[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
3 P
เป็น ch th dans le bouddhisme chacun est
libre de ses croyances et de la façon de
les
pratiquer par exemple en Thaïlande
beaucoup de gens croient que les
tatouages nous protègent et sont des
signes de
vertu chaque année une cérémonie a lieu
pour honorer le maître des moines
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tatoueurs
[Musique]
à soukum vit l'un des quartiers les plus
animés de Bangkok se trouve l'atelier de
tatouage de Jimmy Wang il est l'un des
tatoueurs les plus connus en
Asie
Jimmy Wong a commencé à tatouer pendant
la guerre du Vietnam au contact des j
américains stationnés en
Thaïlande en plus de 40 ans de carrière
il a pratiqué tous les styles de
tatouage polynésien japonais
occidentaux dans cette région du monde
il existe deux types de tatouage le
premier type est le tatouage
cabalistique il s'agit de tatouages
rituel fait par des moines et réalisés à
la main le deuxième type ce sont les
tatouages artistique que je fais moi ici
dans ma boutique en servant d'une
machine à
encre tous les ans je me rends au temple
pour honorer le maître tatoueur c'est un
jour très important les disciples du
temple et les moines toueur de toute la
Thaïlande se rassemble pour cette
cérémonie très
particulière Jimmy Wong est un disciple
de ce temple depuis plus de 25
ans beaucoup de Me
auourd'hui comme chaque année il vient
pour le crew littéralement le jour où
l'on honore le
maître la date pour ce rassemblement est
fixée au lendemain de la 3e pleine lune
de notre
calendrier les célébrations vont se
dérouler pendant une journée et toute
une
[Musique]
nuit en fait ces tatouages font partie
de nos tradition
il sinspire de la croyance boudhque
thaïlandaise les gens viennent ici pour
se faire tatouer et à travers ces
tatouage recevoir une
protection dans la vie d'un bouddhiste
il est d'usage de se faire moine pendant
au moins un an du coup en Thaïlande les
temples sont de véritables lieux de vie
les moin de tous les âges viennent pour
acquérir le savoir et prier mais aussi
pour y trouver le G et le couvert
un temple est conçu comme une petite
cité avec ses quartiers le quotidien s'y
déroule dans une ambiance festive et
détendue les grands Mo tatoueurs sont
invités au temple aujourd'hui tous les
disciples tatoués doivent être là pour
rendre hommage au maître du temple ce
temple est unique ici on peut se faire
tatouer par les moines ce n'est que dans
ce temple qu'on peut faire les tatouages
sacrés pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
et pourquoi avez-vous fait votre
tatouage ici parce que je crois en leur
pouvoir on doit le respect au moins de
[Musique]
tatoueur
tout événement dans un temple commence
par des offrandes et une cérémonie
moines et fidèles se mélang accroupis à
même le
sol les incantations ont ici un rôle
essentiel les Manra aide les disciples à
entrer en communion avec l'esprit du
[Musique]
maître
faire des offrandes pour honorer le
grand maître c'est de respect à mémoire
maîreous leque de
l'ermitei on se sent plus fort avant
d'aller se
faire
[Musique]
le rituel du van va crew remonte à
l'époque où l'école se faisait dans les
temples et les professeurs étaient des
moines au temple du tigre c'est
aujourd'hui devenu un pèlerinage annuel
pour tous les moines tatoueurs de
Thaïlande et des pays
[Musique]
avoisinant après avoir reçu les mantras
protecteurs du maître les moines se
dispersent dans tout le temps piquer les
symboles protecteurs sur la peau des
centaines de fidèles venus pour
l'occasion en Thaïlande la légende
raconte qu'avant de partir au combat les
guerriers se rendaient chez les moin
pour se faire tatouer à l'issue d'une
cérémonie mystique les dessins magiques
leur été gravés sur la peau ainsi parais
les guerriers pouvaient aller sansinte à
les lames ne les toucherai pas
aujourd'hui les fidèles peuvent recevoir
ce pouvoir en échange d'offrande au
temple sakan est le nom thaïlandais pour
les tatouages réalisés par les religions
ils sont constitués de diagramm magique
d'imag d'idole et de représentation
animale l'écriture est du chrome
l'ancien langage écrit cambodgien du 13e
siècle uniquement utilisé par les
moines
le temple vbang pra fut dirigé avant sa
mort par le grand moine
Perne cet homme était un grand maître en
magie blanche et en sorcellerie il était
respecté dans tout le pays pour sa
science des tatouages
religieux à sa mort en 2002 son corps se
serait miraculeusement momifié il est
exposé à la vénération des fidèles dans
un cercueil de verre
le symbole du tigre concerne directement
notre maître le
moine en effet je Mo il faisait un
pèlerinage dans la forêt
dechanabour il y avait des tigres autour
de l'endroit où il avait installé son
campement le soir un tigre a fait le
tour de sa
tente est entré en méditation devant le
tigre et le tigre n'a pas tué le moine
il estti dans la
forêt épisode notre maître s'est servi
du tigre comme symbole de son
[Musique]
tatouage aujourd'hui les gens continuent
à croire au pouvoir sacré des tatouages
de protection de ce
temple les Gou seè les attaques avec des
armes contre les balles et les accidents
de voiture je ne peux rien vous dire de
plus il faut y
croire les fidèles affluent en silence
dans l'espoir de recevoir un tatouage
que seul choisira le moine tatoueur le
temps est compté pas plus de 20 minutes
pour chacun des assistants sont chargés
de bien tendre la peau du fidèle pour
aider le moine dans sa technique l'outil
à tatouer est une longue aiguille
métallique fendue à son extrémité pour
recueillir l'encre de Chine
durant cette journée très spéciale les
moines travaillent pour quelques
offrandes et tous les dons sont destinés
au coffre du
temple ceux qui entendent conserver une
certaine discrétion sur leurs croyances
se font tatouer à l'encre de sesâes
transparentes mais à l'effet magique
tout aussi
[Musique]
bénéfique
le moine long pipéo est un des C
disciplle à avoir reçu l'enseignement de
l'art des tatouages directement du grand
[Musique]
maître
je dois tout d'abord commencer par
l'écriture des
caractères puis je récite les
incantations en fonction des tatouages
le principal c'est de pratiquer tout le
temps aujourd'hui les fidèles sont venus
nombreux pour honorer le maître en
thaand les G sont très ce qui se passe
dans les temples on respectees croyances
deputempsad transmise de génération en
génération l'atmosphère est silencieuse
mais l'attention reste palpable certains
pèlerins méditent alors que d'autres
n'arrivent pas à contrôler le pouvoir de
leur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tatouage les tatouages sont liés aux
incantations sacré remonte à nos
ancêtres les gens qui se font tatouer
deviennent plus fort que la
normale et surtout quand ils se font
tatouer dans ce temple la Trance peut
vraiment se
produire chaque tatoué a sa propre
histoire certains ont fait l'expérience
de graves accidents mais ils étaient les
seuls à s'en sortir on ne savait pas si
c'était un miracle ou de la
chance en fait cela dépend de la
croyance de
chacun sous les habits des travailleurs
de Bangkok se cach souvent des
protections sacrées dans chaque métier
dangereux on se protège comme grce au
amulettes et au tatouag les voyou et les
bandit disent même que leur pouvoir fait
rebondir les balles des pistolets et
dévier les lames des
couteaux est moto taxi il cro en ses
protections il est sorti ind de TR gros
accidents de la
route avec M toues je me sens protégé
bien sûr je ne sais évidemment pas si
c'est grâce à la chance ou à le pouvoir
je fais une prière tous les matins grâce
à ça j'ai des clients qui me payent pour
de bonnes
courses
je gagne beaucoup plus d'argent que les
autres j'ai toujours la foi qu je
conduis j'ai commencé à me faire tatouer
avec le grand moine venant
de prier
le le de la compassion ce caractère
s'appelle leur
boud maî c'est aussi la figure
emblématique de
mon ça c'est le tigre ça symbolise la
vie éternelle la force la puissance et
bien s le pouir V đu đng là
hả
au fil des années et des miracles
l'événement a pris de l'ampleur le
temple est aussi devenu un haut lieu de
rencontre de la père locale de la police
et de tous ceux qui exercent une
profession à
risque pendant toute la nuit les fidèles
vont être tatoués à la chaîne dans des
conditions précaires l'hygiène est plus
que douteuse et la stérilisation
absente
[Musique]
les savoirs sacrés du maître peuvent
nous aider quand on est en danger ou en
difficulté dans les périodes difficiles
de la
vie normalement c'est le moine tatoueur
qui décide des symboles qu'il va touer
par exemple plein de gens demandent le
tigre final c'est le moine qui choisit
avant d'être tatoué on doit rendre
hommage au grand maître en fa graver sur
la peau le symbole temp
c'est celui du C les ne
[Musique]
étages l'isttoire thaïlandaise nous
enseigne qu'on a gagné plusieurs guerres
contre la Birmanie en fait les guerriers
thaïlandais é tout simplement protégé
par les tatouages des Mo pour cette
raison on a souvent repoussé ceux qui
ont essayé d'envahir notre
[Musique]
pays
pendant le tatouage j'ai senti comme du
vent passant à travers moi je suis entré
en méditation et en prière j'ai perçu
comme quelque chose qui entrait dans mon
corps j'en
[Musique]
tremblais les diagrames sont apposés sur
les endroits purs du corps c'est-à-dire
audessus de la
ceinture tatoueur applique uniquement
des pièces du MTA mahaniom la magie
blanche ils sont supposés transmettre
une puissance spirituelle positive
véritable protection les représentations
d'animaux et des dieux hindou préservent
un grand nombre de malheurs à condition
que le fidèle adopte une attitude
exemplaire en conformité avec son
tatouage pour cela il faut s'abstenir de
voler de tuer de commettre l'adultère de
mentir sur autruie et de consommer des
substances nocives ce sont les C précep
[Musique]
boudhisme
lorsque le jour se lève des milliers de
visiteurs se
retrouvent en famille entre amis souvent
jeunes les gens affluent de tout le pays
pour assister à l'événement de l'année
un hôtel gigantesque à l'effigie du
maître Perne a été érigé les fidèles y
déposent leurs offrandes au fil des
heures latention
[Musique]
monte la cérémonie doit commencer à 9h39
et 9 secondes
précisément cet horaire a été choisi car
le chiffre 9 est considéré dans
plusieurs pays d'Asie comme le chiffre
le plus auspicieux promettant chance et
[Musique]
longévité une fois scarifi les esprit
DESS il pr pour les divinités qu'ilte
sur en récitant des
mantras la foule assiste alors des scè
d'ystéri collec lesèlerins entr en
prnent les postures des animaux tatoués
sur le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
corpi qui le tigre
un autre grogne à l'image du dieu singe
anouan le serpent se contorionne à même
le sol pour éviter les incidents des
hommes ceinturent le posséd tandis que
d'autres lui soufflent dans l'oreille
seule technique pour faire disparaître
[Applaudissements]
l'esprit
des animaux qu'il se sont fait tatouer
sur le corps prennent possession
d'eux ça para incroyable pour les
étrangers mais en Thaïlande on a
l'habitude de voir ce genre de chose
pour nous c'est
[Applaudissements]
normal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
đ
KH
le tatouage est avant tout un rituel
initiatique
spirituel les fidèles doivent en
principe observer des règles très
strictes après avoir été
tatoué je savais en me faisant tatouer
qu'il ne fallait pas boire d'alcool
c'est un des précepts de base en fait
j'ai pas fait attention aux conséquences
j'en ai bu juste un peu ensuite j'ai
perdu la conscience c'est très sérieux
quand il est arrivé à la maison je ne le
reconnaissais plus il s'est mis par
terre en grattant comme un tigre il y a
encore les traces comme les griffes d'un
tigre sur le
pilier la tr'estite dès que j'ai
commencé à boire le 4e
ver je me suis senti tellement bizarre
que mes poils se
soulevaient j'ai continu encore à boire
et au 5e ver tout à coup j'ai une perte
de
conscience je me suis senti partir
[Musique]
regardez il a fait ça avec ses ongles là
et là encore là on a essayé de l'enlever
du pilier mais on y arrivait
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pas
[Musique]
grâce à leur pouvoir les tatouages
sacrés San sont décidément bien loin des
tatouages esthétiques que les gensborent
en
Occident sont portés par des personnes
de tous les niveaux de la société
thaïlandaise du plus simple paysan
jusqu'à l'important
[Musique]
politicien cette année encore le jour où
l'on honore le maître a rassemblé une
foule immense et lorsqu'il faut bénir
11000 personnes les moines tatoueurs
depuis leur hôtel utilisent tout
simplement des LAN incendie reliés à des
réservoir de
bénite au final 2 au temple du tigre
permet de découvrir un autre visage du
bouddhisme et l'une de ces pratiques les
plus surprenantes en
[Musique]
Asie
M r r
th bắ
th